i'm alexi lucan a principal dsp engineer  at izotope  and i'm proud to accept this award on  behalf of the entire team  mike rosett jefferson hobbs mark ethier  and over a hundred talented people at  izotope thank you for leading us into  the future  we are working on it 18 years ago  i developed a few technical ideas that  would later become isotope rx  this transformation of 100 lines of  c-plus plus code  into the industry standard suite of  tools for audio repair  would not be possible without the  amazing feedback from our customers  dialogue editors restoration engineers  audio producers talking to those people  about their  creative needs has empowered and  inspired us to make  impossible ways of audi editing a  reality thank you academy for this honor  you